we are at the norman hotel which is a
beautiful hotel we're just awesome suite
this is where Conan he had done
something would found and he
interrogated the main star where his gal
gadot they listened to behind her for
that we're here shooting a nice cameo
with its gal gadot who couldn't be a
nicer person one of the loveliest people
I've met in show business or anywhere so
nice so we're gonna do a thing where I'm
being a creep which is a role that seems
to find me often and I'm knocking on I
found her in Tel Aviv and I'm bringing a
sweater I'm saying that I think she left
it when she's on my show and it's
clearly not her sweater and then I'm
just trying to get into the apartment so
yeah it's not on the crate first is
Wonder Woman I think we know who's gonna
win okay I'll go do touch-ups and then
we're ready to go great yeah you need a
lot of words I know Conan no next to you
no one's gonna be looking at you this is
exciting
[Music]
hey how are you you are very hard to
find you found me yet I did find you
alive how are you
[Applause]
Shalom when you get in I bought in a
while ago and then I heard you playing
like it wasn't easy if people do not
want to tell me where you live it's very
tenacious I tell you yeah okay so I'll
see you tonight
yeah bye-bye nice to see you
[Applause]
that was
I get a sense you've done that you're
very you don't have a very good polite
that's not happening shut down very nice
with your family
you're supposed to kiss now yeah we just
finished shooting with Gao and she's
extraordinary and really funny a great
improviser and it's about as happy as I
get I'm gonna go grab a cup of coffee
and think about what just happened here
for a few years
you